[Music]
and naps for Health News for You Gina I
picked it actually love naps right
excellent I can't take naps no more yeah
I'm too heartbroken oh here we go
are you gonna put this in every video
the first news our gala we talked about
we should change every title to break up
like napping after breakups everything
about breakups when I was sad though I
still nap when I'm sad so if you hate a
nap submitted by fuckles hermanos oh man
yeah brothers yeah wait what's hermano a
brother right brothers
hey isn't that from Breaking Bad yeah
Boyle hermanos come on us man I want to
sell meth so bad people who nap
regularly may be less likely to suffer a
heart attack I have the healthiest heart
but as you know if you oversleep and
sleep don't break our door you'll do
this to me please don't do this you're a
dream killer job you know if you stable
and I ensure that I hurt like that if
you lower your blood pressure through
the naps but then you wake up and
immediately you go on fire on Twitter
and you can raise it all up again how
long are your nuts like three hours
that's not sleeping here's the thing all
right let's talk about this okay my
master sleeps my sleep sarcomas okay
wait you're seriously how long your
sleeps 12 hours of work oh my well
that's because you have insomnia yeah
you manic are you are you bipolar mm-hmm
I would hope not I think I'm pretty [ __ ]
you Nikki Nikki she's not bipolar
I am oh we are you manic and you like
stay up all like I'm hypomania
that's almost bipolar oh then you don't
get a depression part no that's Jess
yeah so you're not bipolar you're just
one polar high hypomania is like in the
monomer
Haller for there's fool mania like manic
depressed and bipolar or mania and
Ender's hypomania it's like in the
middle and then so you get all the
benefits of bipolar were yeah all the
benefit huh it's like a new and improved
man I want this holy [ __ ] so it's like
you get that you get the you get the
swings of extreme emotion but not the
tiredness oh this is great
so you're extremely happy most of it no
no there is hypomania though no but it's
like it's like saying it's like saying
like okay so there's full full-on
bipolar in this right like when you when
II when you have the extreme case of it
it's like you when you express when you
experience the downs of it it's like
you're so [ __ ] Dow you got to go to
sleep you can't move and it's like it
[ __ ] up your life hypomania on the
other hand you go through the same
similar swings but it's not debilitating
it's like a functioning depressed person
exactly but when you hit the highs which
I'm in right now you only need a few
hours of sleep you're just constantly
going and expressing and creating and
all that stuff so they're saying like a
lot of people that are like high work
ethics but then like constant energy
might have that - I've always been like
this since I was kid like I wanted naps
every day after school like I never
fought against naps or anything I'm
about it I'm about that life
I didn't Maps hey didn't axis but um so
your naps are longer than one hour right
all right so this time I'm doing
whatever it is yeah so they're saying
that if you nap regularly and if your
naps are less than an hour long thing
that that's when you get the benefits
here about hour 20 minutes 20 minutes
I tried the whole 20-minute nap thing it
does help a lot more yeah and I don't
wake up all groggy well you got to sleep
a full eight and then do 220 me yeah
if you can't map though they're saying
that meditation is just as fine what I
can't shut off I have to nap like on my
back though otherwise I sleep longer
than 20 minutes it has to be on my back
and then I wake up at like exactly 20
minutes the other day I got really tired
so I went to the backyard and I sat in a
chair fell asleep like an old
belly thing damn I missed that one [ __ ]
you put my hands in my pocket
dude that is one old man Nikki's old man
falls asleep like that every [ __ ] bag
hand in his pants still amazing
no he really is like that the chair
doesn't even have a high back oh you
know you don't sheriff talking about the
one when you had it placed under a tree
so I was like Oh shade so I sat down the
back of that chair is like down here why
did you put your hand in your pants
what's the point of it I'm comfy you
ever done
there's no armrest an armrest so there's
no armrest I have to put it in my pocket
it hurts like honey you don't have any
armrest and you just like broke his neck
yeah it doesn't like you broken oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah absolutely
that's nice together meditation has been
helping me with when I get too hyper or
if it is anxiety I don't know what it is
but I'm just like yeah or oh [ __ ]
something scary and I don't know what
the hell is happening but nothing's to
be scared about yeah yeah yeah I just go
breathe breathe and then it starts going
away
that's my make you for sure yes yeah
that's like me oh yeah mm-hmm many years
they're all weird as [ __ ] she has more
anxiety that's weird girl 12 hours I've
done that from time to time so you're
technically not 30 yet because you
haven't really lived as many years
you're still 22 I spend less hours
moving my face so the wrinkles aren't
there
it's not Botox at all and I wake up
greasy so like all that moisturizes me
Wow
the more I know about you the more
disgusting that's my joke what is it all
the time I don't know why but she has a
[ __ ] army of men just ready to like I
can't wait to be with Gina I'm like
she's like not even my little sister
she's my little brother Jaime Cheadle
fingered little brothers yeah is the
female version of a microwave burrito
yeah yeah like that's how I trap him
first like I trapped them and I look
really nice and gradually just yeah
because you show up in your designer
clothes with all your like your bags and
like you're cute sunglasses yeah no it's
all a lie all right so this story here
there was this new study published in
the British Medical Journal where
research researchers began analyzing
health and sleep data in 2009 from 3642
randomly selected participants ages 35
to 75 in Switzerland and they were
recruited through the Swiss National
Health Survey and they found so first of
all they first asked there about the
previous weekly nap frequency and then
they would continue monitoring them for
an average of five years per participant
so most which was 58% did not nap
regularly and one in five people which
was 19% said they took one to two naps
in a week and about one in ten which is
12% took three to five naps weekly and
about 11% were taking nearly daily naps
Wow they found a lot of mappers who did
not nap at all had a 48 percent higher
likelihood of experiencing a stroke
heart attack or failure so any
cardiovascular disease isn't because
they're like more are they smoke a
cigarette
are they on meth or you know
so they did have those like they
controlled think yes - yeah yeah I think
they did factor the only variable is the
nap yeah a nap more yes you do
siesta siesta yeah more than an hour
because that's not a real map that's a
sweeping yeah I'm sorry yes so why do
you have trouble sleeping I really don't
know I think is this green time yeah I
think so too
blue light you don't go outside and feel
the Sun and you don't move your body I
forced myself to go out the Sun and just
like maybe you have too much energy that
maybe it's because you don't move see
the thing is there are days when like I
wake up at 4:00 in the morning and I
like go do crazy [ __ ] my friends or like
go hiking camping a [ __ ] else before the
morning go go happy hiking and camping
camping something like yeah like if we
go on trips okay just go and I have like
the full as long as you like driving to
run unifor in the morning early and I'm
filming you guys when I'm doing a [ __ ]
ton of stuff but when I get home it's
still the same thing I don't get tired
until like 6:00 or 7:00 in the morning
again oh well they actually like
biologically they were doing a study
that like you people are naturally a
nighttime person or a daytime person
it's just that society runs catered to a
daytime people choices and so yeah and
so like the nighttime people just have a
really hard time like waking up in the
morning lady you dude I'm totally not a
morning person
yeah at all so that that makes sense
because a village would need protection
24/7 yeah we need the night shift in
addition yeah and that makes sense why I
never wanted to go out to clubs cuz I
fall asleep at clubs because I'm such a
morning person you know what else sucks
that's against nighttime people they say
like those people that work graveyard
shifts they tend to live less like they
die sooner car which one is it [ __ ]
likes accelerate for the greatest a new
study every couple weeks I'm like [ __ ] I
can't live my life like this I thought I
was a nighttime person until I started
sweeping yeah I'm hoping that changes
for me I really do but you know whatever
only game I I'm just thankful to agree
we have a kid you'll be up all night
with the kid don't you wish that evil on
me see that's why we work so well cos
he's a nocturnal person and I'm like a
morning person
how do you find time in between like do
you guys just meet up at 6 p.m. and just
basically yeah it was like anytime after
10 p.m. every he's trying to have sex I
can't do it because I'm so tired but if
I try to do it before 10 p.m.
sometimes he's like he has a tummy ache
because he just ate food or something
him like a soit's it's tricky we have to
kind of plan it like hey don't eat food
right some spicy house like let's get
together I like to see it doesn't have
like so you know you can leave today
like tummy-aches she called me I would
never say such a thing
lately it's been headache well no I had
a headache for three days which would
not [ __ ] off three days three day
migraine
it was nuts nothing to do with the
energy drinks it doesn't it has nothing
to do with the lack of water
we're flourishing we're functioning
here's what about 90 okay so we were in
Singapore and I couldn't fall asleep I
was jet-lagged [ __ ] Nikki's like I'll
suck your dick and go to bed
yeah and she did it and it worked yeah
it was like 3:00 in the morning he
couldn't fall asleep that's how it works
I sucked his dick maybe you gotta suck
his dick more why was I was away to your
dick instead of girl oh that's pretty
good not a wig here in America three two
lengths see yeah yeah Jeana if you have
insomnia maybe sex will may help you
sleep maybe you gotta suck someone's
dick really helps me go to sleep if I
can't fall asleep and I gotta wake up
early late every night yeah well not
every night I thought it was every night
well it's in the afternoon or its of the
night so it's a good day
I don't do it at night that's a lot I
try so doesn't work huh I have to be
like drugged the [ __ ] out to go to sleep
oh you just got to get some quaaludes
girl don't lose any more and
masturbation great combination yeah I've
had everything under the like everything
dude yeah
[Music]